does chewing gum release the same
appetite suppressing chemical in weight
loss drugs like OIC you know I was
hesitant to respond to this question
because I think it has the potential to
encourage very disordered behaviors but
you guys ask me about this a lot and I
don't believe in censoring science so
quick little trigger warning let's talk
about it early small studies suggest
that yes chewing gum can help to
stimulate glp1 in the gut which is
responsible for the appetite reduction
scene on drugs like OIC it was also
shown in another study where fullness
levels were significantly greater and
hunger levels were lower in the gum
chewing group than the control now this
was a super small study but it is
consistent with other studies on gum
chewing and Cravings plus more robust
research suggesting that the slower we
eat and the more we thoroughly chew our
food the more satiated we are from the
meal that said the difference in
perceived hunger when chewing gum versus
eating nothing at all is only like a 5
to 20% difference so this study is not
suggesting that chewing a stick of gum
will fill you up like you're still going
to be hungry because you've eaten
nothing at all please do not take this
research as an invitation to like chew
gum all day instead of actually eat next